Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a lot of
time on this.
It's quite dense.
It's worth reading on your own.
But ProPublica did a really interesting study
of the richest, richest Americans.
And what they looked at is how much in taxes
the richest Americans paid relative to how
much their wealth grew during the same time
period.
Now, a lot of this has to do with unrealized
gains.
And I'm going to explain that in a moment.
But this is one of the ways in which the rich
really benefit the super, super, super rich.
I'm not talking about people who make five
hundred K a year.
We're talking about the super super rich in
the United States.
When you have an increase in net worth, this
could be because you earned money by working
or you might have an increase in net worth
because assets you hold increased in value.
If you hold a bunch of stocks, a million dollars
in stocks and they go up and they're worth
two million dollars in stocks, your net worth
just went up by a million dollars.
You don't owe any taxes other than on the
dividends, depending on what type of account
those funds are.
Stocks are held then.
Right.
So but the gist of it is you don't owe any
taxes on that gain of a million dollars in
net worth until you realize the gain by selling
those stocks.
So what you've seen over the last from 2014
to twenty eighteen is that the 25 richest
Americans saw their collective net worth go
up by 400 billion dollars, but they only paid
thirteen point six billion dollars in federal
income taxes.
So that is a three point four percent.
Now, I know many people are going to say,
David, David, hold on, they didn't have a
taxable event.
A lot of that growth in.
Networth came from they held assets and the
assets went up in value.
I have a two million dollar house and the
market explodes and it's worth four million.
My net worth went up to million dollars.
I don't owe any taxes on that, OK?
My real estate taxes might go up a little
if the assessment goes up right.
There's some details.
That's how it works.
David, I understand.
But the analysis is an interesting one nonetheless,
which is when you were already very wealthy,
you were able to increase your net worth with
very little tax exposure for the average person.
If you make 50000 dollars a year and you get
a raise to seventy five thousand dollars a
year, that's a nice raise.
That increase in the net worth you could have
by saving your additional salary is going
to be dragged down by the fact that you're
paying income taxes on that additional salary.
So the investigation is an interesting one
because it exposes the tax on net worth growth,
which is really, really low.
Now, am I proposing a particular change in
policy as a result of the.
No, I have other segments on that, but it's
a very interesting way to look at how by not
realizing gains and by having assets that
grow that are disproportionately already held
by the very rich, you can have a net worth
grow with extremely low drag from taxes, tax
drag, as it is often called.
And it is another one of the ways in which
just increasing income taxes, which is often
what the discussion is, it's what we're talking
about now with Joe Biden, does very, very
little to actually capture the vast majority
of the benefit to the ultra, ultra ultra rich.
We're talking about multibillionaires here.
This is a very different thing than someone
with a small business like Joe the Plumber's,
which supposedly made two hundred and fifty
thousand a year but didn't actually very,
very different situation